yeah you know that's things you think
about when you're a kid man
you you wonder what it's like you you
you strive to
hear that and to to do it with this team
and this group man it couldn't be any
more special
all right we're we'll go to uh
jp hornstrom jp go ahead
hey corey uh congratulations thank you
we asked you a lot of people before this
game and after the last one
you know to look forward to what it
might feel like and i'm just wondering
for you like in reality
did you truly not think about
this until that final out was recorded
or did you start to get excited there
even before the final half
you know you really can't you know the
nerves definitely start creeping in you
know
towards the end of the game um but you
know you gotta shut them out you gotta
you gotta finish the job you know
we know more than anybody that the
game's not over until you make 27 outs
so
to to be able to finally accomplish that
get the last out win the last game you
know
it's it's surreal and it's unbelievable
all right we'll go to jorge castillo
jorge go ahead what was your action when
they pulled snow
um you know he was tough all night uh
you tip your cap to a man
he threw a hell of a ball game um he had
us off balance he made pitches we
we grinded we battled and you know we
didn't really have an answer for him and
and once he kind of came out you know it
uplifted us a little bit for sure you
know
we started feeling a little momentum you
know we scratched a few runs and you
know and we ended up winning
we'll go to tim brown tim go ahead
great i know it's almost appropriate
um given the season you guys have been
through that in the eighth inning
um one of your best friends and one of
your best players gets removed
from from the game what was that like
what
where have you seen him since um
uh i don't know what do you know about
all that
yeah you know like you said you know you
don't even really know what to ask
um we don't even know what to ask you
know
to have that happen to a guy like that a
dude that's reinvented himself when he
came here
what he's meant to this organization
what he's meant to this franchise what
he's meant to this community
and to to take that away from him you
know it's gut-wrenching you know it
hurts me
i can't imagine how he feels you know if
i could
switch places with him right now i would
that that man more than anybody deserves
to
take a picture with that trophy
celebrate with us you know have his
family around and
enjoy this moment and you know that got
taken away from him and
that's that's just not right you know
that doesn't sit well with me
in the dugout were you aware what was
happening did you see him walk away
i didn't you know i found out a couple
hours later you know when we were
running out right when we were running
out i i
heard him talking about the move and and
stopped and asked and
they said what happened and you know
even in the moment it's gun wretching
you know you you don't know what to do
you want that man beside you you know
i've played a lot of games beside him
we we've we've done a lot on this field
and to not be able to have him there
and finish it and to be able to
accomplish what we did you know
that hurts it hurts a lot
ron go ahead
there can you hear me
do you think given what happened to
being hurt two years ago and the
frustrations
that you had three years ago the meaning
for you
was different than it would have been
had it come the first time
um you know not really you know it's
to be able to win and to be able to to
do it with a team like this you know
it means everything you know obviously
going through the injuries and
and everything like that and missing out
on a world series chance it hurt you
know obviously
um but to be able to come back and get
back in the same place with a with the
team that's been there and
this core has been around for a couple
years now and to know what it feels like
to lose and
and to be able to rebuild and come back
and stay focused and to be able to
finish it you know
it's special
i'm like do you teach you go ahead
hey corey you won this game with some
guys on the mound that uh
you probably wouldn't consider the
bigger names in your bullpen what did
you think of the effort especially sort
of
uh writing things early on not letting
things get out of hand
yeah you know you can't say enough about
our pen our pitchers our starting staff
you know
i mean what they've done all year and
how they've been able to do it and
just absolutely keep us in ball games
and keep us close you know
get us back in games let us get some
momentum and then have big innings where
they shut them down you know
you can't say enough about what they did
you know
offense gets portrayed more because you
have to score to win but man
without those guys you know we're not
here we're not in the same spot
we're we're probably at home already so
to have those guys man it's fun to watch
and we'll finish up with jp hornstrom
still had the hand up sorry okay well
corey congratulations on being the world
series mvp
great great achievement world series
okay okay first question
all right we're gonna get started with
dave roberts the manager of the 2020
world champion los angeles dodgers
i like the ring of that too and the
first question goes to alana rizzo
congratulations doc you knew it why was
this the year
i just i i had a crazy feeling that came
to fruition and
um it's just a special group of players
um organization just all that we've kind
of overcome
i just knew that we weren't going to be
denied this year
how emotional is it for you to go
through this and then see one of your
best players can't participate like you
wanted to
yeah that this that that that hurts um
and i haven't had a chance to see
justin yet and i don't even really know
you know all that went into it i just
knew that
i had to get him out of the game in the
seventh inning and
after the seventh inning and so um i'm
still trying to learn but i can't wait
to see him
you're a world series champion um you
know what i'm kind of
looking at everyone and celebrating
everyone else so
uh it's sinking in pretty quickly and
i'm just
i'm obviously i'm over the moon and uh
happy for julio and
you know clayton that you know when
people talk about him it's world series
champion first
you know then future hall of famer and
uh
and you know for ken lee justin just
everybody i'm just so excited for all
these guys
we'll go to jorge castillo jorge
and congratulations um what was your
reaction when they pulled
blake snow i i was pretty happy
um because he was uh dominating us and
we just weren't seeing him so
you know once austin got that hit and
they went to the pen i think that mookie
looked at me with a little smile
and we were just all kind of excited
that snow is out of the game
now we'll go to um
alden gonzalez on go ahead hey dave
congratulations
um what did you say to clinton when your
first husband
i don't know all then i just told him
how happy i was
for him and thanking him and how
grateful i was to
you know be beside him um
basically just kind of sharing and he
was excited for me as well
we'll go uh we'll go to
mike dg ivana he's congrats man
thanks dg what'd you make of your
bullpen
effort uh not a lot of big names in this
game and how cool is it to have julio
finish it out
considering the postseason he's actually
it's so great and
you know for for flo for woody uh for
victor uh bazooka uh you know bruce dar
and julio to do what he did all those
guys and it's just you look up and down
our roster everyone contributed and
um came up big for us
we're going to barry bloom barry go
ahead
thanks mikey hey congratulations
thanks barry i'm happiest help for you
really
i know how hard you work for this uh
what was the process of you being told
that you had to take turner out of the
game yeah it was basically uh
the trainer telling me that he had to
come out uh immediately
um because he tested positive so
um at that point time i was trying to
still manage a game to get other guys
you know ready to go and
i haven't seen justin yet so uh that's
all i know
okay tyler kepner tyler go ahead
say congratulations very happy for you
um
i wanted to uh to ask you now that it's
over um
you thought the other day about the how
the guys from you know the 80s were
always great to you and pulling for you
um but now that it's over how big of a
burden was that
32-year wait how much did that hang over
you and this franchise
well first off you know those guys from
the 80s
the guys prior you know obviously tommy
oral
all these guys ron say
boomer these guys have all been great
and supportive to us
uh gibby but to have our own moment um i
i think um
is is great for the city of los angeles
great for the dodgers and i think
they're happy too
i know they're happy so um you know i i
mean i guess burden's a word but i'm
just happy that
uh we finally did it
we'll go to ron blum ron go ahead
on the play on corey's grounder with
mookie running
did you know before you saw where the
infield lined up that he was going to go
on contact
yeah no i made that decision no we made
that decision you know when corey came
up
you know just understanding that mookie
will get a great jump on on the swing
and
and i trust him so we're going to go in
contact right there
congratulations thank you
we'll go to pedro gomez pedro go ahead
hey dave felicidades um
how much of a burden has been lifted off
of you personally
given how how much you've been
criticized the last few years for not
winning it
yeah you know um i i'm just you know i i
think for me i try to not make things
personal about me pedro and you know me
i'm just
really happy for the organization um i'm
happy for the players i'm happy to
help you know lead this team to a
championship but uh
you know there's always going to be
skeptics but at least you know this is
something that
no one can take away from us
and we'll take a last question from uh
bill plunkett bill go ahead
congratulations dave
thank you bill uh when you sent julio uh
into the game did you expect him to be
the last pitcher you would use
uh you know what i didn't know i just
liked him right there uh to get out of
that spot
and i just felt that you know as long as
he's throwing the baseball well and
feels good we're gonna keep running them
but uh
i really didn't know what to expect i
was hoping he would come out throw the
baseball the way he did though
thanks yep all right dave
congratulations
i appreciate it
shortly
all right
[ __ ]
plastic
this is
all right julio congratulations uh we
will get started with julio ryaz
uh we'll start with james wack james
wagner go ahead james
james e there
jason stark jason are you there
julio congratulations when you came into
the game
was it your understanding that you were
going to finish the game
no i just focus on getting the one out
and little by little
little it just went batter by batter and
when i least expected i was
getting the final out
it's a special feeling to be that guy
who gets to throw that pitch
can you describe that
yeah it was the most important out and
everyone was
waiting for that i know that like i said
all of la was expecting that everyone
was waiting for that and i'm
thankful to god that we were able to
achieve it
all right we'll go to atlanta rizzo
atlanta
what point you're going to enter
they told me to get ready for the fourth
batter and i have the experience of
coming out of the bullpen i know how to
get ready and i was just ready for that
fourth
what does it mean to you to be the
pitcher that closes up the game that
wins the world series for the first time
in 32 years
like i said before it's the most
important out it's the most important
pitch it's a beautiful feeling you know
everybody is waiting for that out and
i'm thankful
to god for the opportunity and i'm
thankful for all the blessings
uh bill plunkett go ahead bill
over the years with the dodgers how
aware did you become of the 32-year wait
is
a lot obviously the dodgers are a famous
team in mexico and you're familiar
with the team and what it means to have
that blue
on and i'm just happy for my teammates
and i'm happy that we were able to
achieve it
pedro gomez go ahead pedro
what does this mean for the latin people
of los
angeles
is it like a victory for mexico for you
no totally
okay
julio congratulations appreciate it
really all right
clayton kershaw world series champion
congratulations thank you
dallas native so it's like a storybook
and we'll start with uh alana rizzo
i only get two questions first and
foremost congratulations i know how much
this means to you
um can you put into words kind of what
you were feeling when you
saw that last out and you came out of
the bullpen
thank you um no i can't yet it's just uh
i've been saying you know world series
champs in my head over and over again
just to see if it'll sink in and um
it just so no i can't put it into words
yet
i'm just so so very thankful to be a
part of this group of guys
and uh so very thankful that we get to
be on the team
that is bringing back a world series to
the dodger fans after 32 years
and uh they've waited a long time and
to get to do that to get to be on the
team that did that in la
because you couldn't ask for anything
more it's incredible
you literally have done everything in
your power
to achieve this to be able to do it with
this particular group of guys
in a in a pandemic year does that make
it even more special
uh you know i think this year has been
crazy obviously um
but you know no matter what you know
we'll we'll look back on this and we're
world series champs and
to get to say that and get to get to be
a part of it um
i i it's so special no matter what
to be with this group of guys you know
the only thing that maybe would have
made it better was if we were at dodger
stadium tonight to get to do it
um which is a bummer that we're not but
there are so many dodger fans here
tonight this place was all dodger fans
the whole time and
um to get to see you know it was only 10
000 people here tonight or whatever but
i bet 9 000 of them were dodger fans
that all stuck around after and cheered
for us and
um i'm so happy for them i'm so happy
for the guys in that clubhouse
i'm so happy for my wife that she it's
just
she's just the sense of relief that she
has that we finally did it
and uh for my whole fam i mean just the
the people that are think just
happy for me um it's just it's
overwhelming just to see the support
and um i i'm just so thankful to
everybody that's reached out and
um everybody that's made this possible i
will go to tyler kepner then
tyler go ahead
tyler okay we can go to somebody else
let's go to um you can go to stephanie
epstein
go ahead stephanie hey clayton
congratulations thanks
um you've you've been thinking about
this for a long time
what's different about it now that it's
happened than what you dreamed
i don't know i mean i don't i don't
think anything's different i just
i think it's it's a great feeling and
it's uh
you know there's a lot of emotions that
go into it i think just like pure joy
for one to have your dream that you've
worked
so hard for realized um
just thankful i think is another one to
be a part of this team this group of
guys
there's definitely a sense of relief you
know i think that we did it
and we've been the best team the whole
year
we've been the best team before too and
haven't won so to get to
be the best team throughout the whole
year make it through this crazy playoff
run and to win the world series is a
pretty special accomplishment
and uh i'm not going to take that for
granted for sure
tyler kepner clayton congratulations um
yeah you know last year in the clubhouse
after the last game of the season
was was really tough obviously for you
um what do you think this championship
and the way you pitched all month
is going to mean for your legacy and
what do you think you proved
just uh just by season to everybody yeah
those are all bad
questions i don't care about any of that
man we won the world series i don't care
about legacy
i don't care about what happened last
year i don't care about
what people think of i don't care at all
man we won the world series
the night the 2020 dodgers won the world
series that like
who cares about all that other stuff to
be a part of that team
all that other stuff is just pointless
it doesn't matter we won
it's great we'll go to ron blum
hi clayton congratulations at all the
times
you guys came so close and fell short
were there ever any moments that you
started to
doubt that you would ever get to hear
or think about how just unsatisfying it
felt to you
until now once again man all those other
years don't matter
it doesn't matter who wins you know like
all those other years don't make this
any sweeter
you know like winning the world series
if you're in the playoffs for the first
year is just as sweet
so like this is what we've worked for
our whole lives like this is
every single one of those guys that has
worked their whole lives to be a part of
a world series championship team myself
included
so nobody those other years are
done with somebody won the world series
and it wasn't us and now we
are the ones that won the world series
and that i i can't get over saying that
it's just amazing
jorge castillo jorge go ahead and a lot
of guys have said is the best team
they've ever played on
and they just felt so confident going
into this postseason what made this team
that you know
if you think so the best team you played
on and he's so confident going into this
october
um you know i don't compare other teams
never have
we've been i've been on some great teams
but this team was really really special
all the way through every faction of our
team offense defense starters bullpen
there's been so many
amazing people talent guys that fit
their roles so well
guys that always believe that we're in
the game a conviction to win every
single day
some of those things you just can't
teach so um
credit to andrew dock all those guys to
put this group of guys together
um but i don't you know this is the best
team i've ever been a part of we won the
world series best team ever been on
alana go ahead
clayton there is no question your
leadership role on this team but how
difficult is it to see jt not be able to
celebrate in the way in which he wants
to is as deserving as he is as well
i'm sure it's really hard tonight and we
all feel for him
um but i i hope
that he can take solace in the fact that
we're not here without him
he is he's been our guy for a long time
he's done so many incredible things for
this organization
um he's been the rock in the postseason
for us every single year
and they just like tonight might not be
the night that we expected as a team or
that he expected individually
they'll never be able to take away the
world series championship from any of us
so it might not be the same tonight as
other teams get to celebrate
and that's not fair obviously to fans
and us and everybody but
we're still the champs and someday
someday soon i hope we are going to
celebrate
and we are going to be there and there's
going to be a parade and there's going
to be
tens of thousands of dodger fans i don't
know when i don't know how soon
but whenever that day comes i know jt is
going to be there and it's going to be a
special thing
tim brown go ahead tim you're one of the
last
out of the bullpen
it wasn't it's not an age question it
was almost as if you wanted to hang back
and take the whole thing in
can you describe what you were seeing it
looked like you found um
your family in the stands can you just
describe
what you saw in that moment yeah i was
trying to take it all in
as best i could um you know i
just looking around and running in front
of the bullpen you know you never really
script what you're going to do or how
you're going to feel
but um just that it was just a
it was a content feeling just like a
job is done you know we won we did it we
won our race
and it's over and we we completed our
mission
and so i think that uh just as just a
feeling of contentment
joy and then to get to see that group of
guys and how happy everybody was
it's only one team gets to do it every
year
and it's not an easy thing to do so it's
just it's just a really special thing
man
uh gabe go ahead uh hey clayton
uh it seemed like your quest to do this
really resonated with a lot of people
and you mentioned uh
feeling happy for people who would you
know
uh did you kind of feel that from dodger
fans and others as well that hey
you know we want to see you get over the
hump and do this
i don't know about all that but i do
know that there's a lot of people out
there that
have always supported me you know
former teammates uh friends family
that have been there every single year
when it hasn't gone our way my way
and my wife
my kiddos my family my friends all those
people
um that have seen the disappointment
before and
they you know they they wanted it just
as bad as i did
and they wanted it for me and that's
such a selfless thing to feel
and so to get those text messages from
former teammates or to get those text
messages from friends or have friends at
the game like i did tonight have family
at the game to
just to see how happy they were for us
for me for our family um
it's it's overwhelming just to think
that people care that much about
about you and how they want you to have
success and
reach your dreams and things like that
so it's not lost on me and i i just uh
it's a i'm just very thankful for every
single person that
has always been in our corner we'll go
to adam mccall me adam
clayton mookie gets that that big devil
after they make the bullpen move tonight
now that it's all said and done how do
you sum up what he meant to this game
this series this post season and sort of
your whole season
yeah i mean mookie's unbelievable
the uh incredible baseball player
does everything so well that everybody
talks about but
you know i think that's he strives to be
perfect
strives to you know be excellent every
single time out there and that focus and
that
consistency i don't know how much better
it made other guys
in this clubhouse but i know it did i
know it did some
and you know you don't want a world
series without any of those 28 guys in
there
you know you don't but obviously he made
a huge impact
on our team a huge impact on our
postseason and
tonight a huge impact on the game
take a couple more for clayton eric
stephen
clayton i'm just wondering uh what dave
roberts meant to you guys this year and
perhaps in in previous years
getting to finally getting the job done
yeah we're happy for doc man you know i
think it's not easy to be a manager it's
not easy to be a manager in the
postseason
but to get through this game the way he
did um
you know to manage the bullpen the way
he did to navigate it through and
you know gave up one home run tonight on
the first inning and then everybody was
matched up the way
that he expected it to go and we won the
game and
so that's just that's a you know tip
your cap to him tip your cap to our
coaching staff front office this is not
a
it's not just a player thing you know we
play the game but there's so many behind
the scenes people that put us in
position to succeed and
he's at the top of that food chain so um
we're all so happy for him
we're so happy for every single person
that had a part in
being a part of this dodger group this
year take a couple last ones kyle glazer
hey clayton you've seen guys like corey
seeger and cody ballinger come up
through the farm system and join this
team over the last few years
what's it been like for you watching all
this talent ascend this homegrown talent
come up and then
culminating in this world series win
tonight yeah
you know talent is god-given you know
talent is something that
there's nothing you can do you know
you're born with talent
so but what i love to see is how
these guys dedicate themselves to get
better how they work
and corey and belly are perfect examples
of that and
the way they've grown into leaders on
our team the way corey was this post
season was
unbelievable um just the way he you know
the focus that can the
intent the drive to make other players
around him better and
um just a special thing man to see all
all those guys that started the way they
are
jock barnesy the postseasons that those
guys had
i love those guys um the way that julio
pitched
you know he and that was incredible you
know obviously walker you know he's been
doing it for a long time but
uh i could just go down the list man i'm
proud of every single one of those guys
that stepped in and filled a role
tonight and for
our whole season clayton you uh are a
world series champion right here where
you grew up so congratulations
keep saying it sounds good thank you
we're all very happy for you
all right congratulations thank you
thank you thank you we're very happy for
you
we will get started with mookie and
we'll uh first
question we'll have alana rizzo
first of all congratulations some people
go their entire career and never have
this
opportunity you now are a world series
champion times two with a new club that
absolutely adores you and welcomes you
with open arms
what does this mean to you uh just means
everything
um you know i was traded for to uh
to help get us over the hump and so i
just used that
as as my fuel um and you know since day
one that was that's
obviously been the goal to win a world
series and so i'm just happy to be a
part of it
you had the home run did you have apart
from the fact you just hit a home run in
the world series
can you appreciate how much of an impact
that home run had in this game given us
some insurance yeah uh you know we
we needed uh to scratch across another
run right there just for uh you know
like you said a little insurance and
um you know that time it came came with
the long ball but uh you know however
however was uh however happened it just
needed to happen
uh pete abraham pete go ahead uh mookie
you've done this twice now how does it
compare to the first time and and what
how different were your emotions uh
tonight
um the first there's there's the first
time is always uh
you know it's different should i say i
mean
obviously the first time i didn't know
necessarily what to expect
um you know this time was i knew what to
expect but
you know my uh my goals my motives were
a little different
um you know like i said i was traded for
for this reason and
i'm uh proud of myself proud of the guys
you know for uh for
accomplishing it tim brown tim
okay a good part of this championship uh
in los angeles
will reflect clayton kershaw because of
the time here because of the effort
because of who he's been
what this year have you learned about
him being a teammate and
and then particularly over the past
month watching him
perform um obviously he's one of the
best teammates you know i've been
been with um one of the the most fierce
competitors you know when he steps on
that mound
he's there to compete you know no matter
what he has that day um
you know he's he's been great for us his
whole career obviously for this year and
i'm just happy to be on the same side of
them uh pedro mora pedro
okay what was the celebration like after
this and was it dampened anyway by
you guys learning that justin and tessa
bowser
uh i think it was it was uh obviously
emotions were high and
everybody was super excited we didn't
get to fully
um celebrate like we wanted to um you
know that kind of sucks that that
happened and um
but you know we eddie came in and and uh
filled in the role
nicely um which uh
you know shows the depth we have but um
you know i'm sure we'll find a way to
celebrate
ken davidoff ken
congratulations uh i'm very sorry to ask
you this we know what happened
with justin uh there are photos on
social media of justin
on the field with you guys after after
the game did you guys see justin there
uh i don't know what anybody said uh
i don't i think he said the photo i i
don't
i mean he's part of the team you know
forget all that you know he's part of
the team you know we can't he
we're not excluding him from anything
we're going to alana rizzo alana
i want to go
lucy having done this before what was it
about this team in particular
that was able to get over the hump it's
one thing to want to win a world series
it's another thing entirely to actually
achieve it
i think we worked so hard from spring
training to to now
um you know we prepared for all these
situations
that came um you know we executed when
it was time to execute
um when our backs were against the wall
we came back um you know we
overcome adversity um so overcame
adversary should i say so i mean we we
everything's special about this group of
guys and you know we uh we love each
other
we played for each other and not just uh
the dodgers and
that's how uh you know great teams are
made ron
blum ron
ronnie there
okay we'll go to tim yeah oh go ahead
ron
yeah if you look at uh what corey did
for the team throughout the whole
postseason he seemed to like
step up almost more than most what is it
about him that
impressed you i mean everything he plays
shortstop well swings the bat well runs
the base as well does everything right
it wasn't just the postseason he did it
all year and so he was huge for us all
year and
he was just steady the whole time
constantly getting two three four hits i
mean
you know it was just uh that's that's
huge in a lineup like ours
and uh you know we just everything he
did was amazing he deserves everything
coming that has came his way and that is
coming his way and
it's a great dude great teammate you
know as sees is just uh
the man and he proved it tim brown tim
go ahead
tim you there
i left my hand up by mistake sorry okay
go ahead gabe
this will be the last one for mookie
uh we'll take one more um kyle glazer
hey mickey dave said you gave him a
smile when blake smell left the game uh
just what were your thoughts when they
pulled snow
ah man it was kind of like a sigh of
relief
um had he stayed in the game he he may
have uh
pitched a complete game and i don't know
exactly what would have happened
but he was rolling and he was he was
pitching really really well
um you know that's the cy young snail
that came tonight um
so you know once he came out of the game
it just uh
like i said it was just a breath of
fresh air um you know we had uh
had some pretty decent bats off their
their bullpen guys
um so we knew we just could figured we
could scratch
you know one across since we saw the
bullpen guys a little better um but
you know snell uh got to tip your cap he
he did
amazing loki you're a champion in your
first year in los
angeles congratulations thank you thank
you thank you appreciate it
i will have an update shortly
world series champion congratulations
very happy for you
uh we'll give the first question to
alana rizzo alana go ahead
jew with your glasses in the jumpman
shirt you are a world series champion
kenley after all
you have been through can you please
describe what goes on in that head of
yours right now
a sight of relief you know we finally
made it
uh we're at champs we're world champs
nobody can take this away from us
we work hard for it and you know
well deserved and you know i'm proud of
every single teammate of
of of mine in the clubhouse everybody
you know
we all did it so um you know to the city
of
la it's it was well deserved for you
guys
you guys needed the most you know 32
years and
here we are at world champs you have
been
so selfless and cheering on every single
person
that has taken over the ninth inning
what does this mean to you to be able to
do this as such a team effort kenley
it's a team effort you know um you know
we all got to pick each other up
and that's why we do that's why we do it
best that's why we're world champs today
because we all
pick each other up and you know i'm
proud of
julio how we step up i'm proud of you
know
everyone everyone um uh
it's it's awesome it's awesome it's i
don't know how to describe this feeling
right now i'm just gonna enjoy it
every single day uh ron blum ron go
ahead
hey kenli do you think this means more
to you now than it would have been how
to come
earlier given all the adversity both the
team overcame and you personally
overcame
you know um everything you got to earn
in life and this is the way how god want
us to go through um for me being
you know every day i'll go to my knees
and pray to god and you know i feel like
this is god's way
you know we learn a lot i learned a lot
in life
and um
you know going to all the adversity and
you know we all we all fought and you
know we all went to
the up and downs and here we are today
you know
we could say we are world champs nobody
can take this away from us it's an
awesome feeling
i'm gonna carry osborne carry on
kenley uh your first game as teammates
with uh justin and clayton all on the
same team was back in sydney australia
um will you remember of that game and
then can you talk about the journey and
what those two guys have meant to you
man a lot i mean knowing kirsch be the
first guy who cut him
and and gulf coast league in 06 see
how he you know go through his career
and got to the big league so quick and
you know got called up in the big
leagues you know my first save
was the game that kirsch was pitching
um and then you know jt arrived
um in 14 i learned so much from him
you know it's an awesome feeling it's
well deserving for
clayton well deserving for jt you know
um it's awesome man it's awesome to be
there
be a part of um you know teammate with
them
um you know i love those guys i love
you know see how they go through their
business and and here we are
man you're a world champ i'm mike
digiovanna mike
kenley you've been such a big part of so
much that has gone on here over the last
however many years just wondering what
it was like for you to
watch the proceedings from the bullpen
tonight and
how weird it kind of was to not be in
that game
as a team man willie was throwing the
ball pretty well
i'm ready anytime that you know the
phone rings
and um you know yes we all want that
moment
but you know who he was throwing the
ball really well and
it's awesome man that's awesome i could
say you know being a dodger
i feel like i'm a true dodger now you
know after 32 years
you know the trophies going back to l.a
it's awesome it's all awesome feeling i
mean you know i will
cherish and remember this moment my
my whole life you know i can you know my
kids was here with me when they get
older you know
i can remind them that this moment you
know that
you know we are world champ uh alana
you have done so much for this
organization and somebody that's been so
proud of you and instrumental is the
late great don nukem
if he were here to see this what do you
think he would think and what do you
think he would say to him
man don rest in peace
um he meant so much for me in my career
helped me so much mentally and
you know um we tried to win one for him
17 and 18. but you know
if he would be here he would say that
you know he finally got it you know
just enjoy this moment i know that's
what he for sure would tell me well
deserved you know and he will tell me
that he loved me as
you know as a father and you know as a
friend
and everything you know so um i know how
close i was to him
and i learned so much from and that's
that's how i feel like i'm a true dodger
today because i was with one of the
legends
you know learned so much from him
and you know now i'm a part of a
of a champion with a dodger so it's an
awesome feeling
diana alvarado
diana
okay we'll go to uh mike digiovanna
mike go ahead
all right we'll go we'll go to ron blum
think we're done all right i think all
right thank you ask me andrew
all right thanks all right all right
respecting andrew friedman uh president
of the dodgers
baseball operations
so
so
oh
okay
so
so
foreign
goodbye
good
tomorrow
so
so
you